in the 2015 film ant-man Scott Lang is
fired for his job when his boss uncovers
his criminal past unable to earn an
honest living language turns to a life
of crime now this is not a far-fetched
scenario many employers are reluctant to
hire the tens of millions of Americans
with criminal arrest records making them
half as likely to be employed as their
demographics would suggest arming and
training armies events in order to save
the world is not a common clear path
instead sizeable numbers of state and
local governments have banned the common
practice of asking job applicants about
the criminal history at the start of the
application process many private sector
firms have adopted similar practices
voluntarily research by Dennis Shoah and
me shows that these policies have
increased employment in high crime
neighborhoods by some 4% especially in
public sector and low wage jobs while
these policies won't make anyone a
superhero they might just help more
Americans enjoy productive dignified
life do you think employers should be
allowed to screen job applicants on the
basis of their criminal history let us
know in the comments also let us know
what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds and be
sure to LIKE and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI